it's funny you mentioned Hamlet there  cuz Joseph said that's the one he'd like  to do next what would he feel if he came  and asked you to do that and what would  you approach me I'd be honoured beyond  measure he'd be amazing I mean my  approach would be to learn the thing  inside out and and let it happen  I suppose that's why it's an interesting  part actually because the actor playing  Hamlet really has to bring themselves to  the role I think not having played it  yet but it seems to me that it's an  amazingly open role and the actor is  asked to think about fathers and mothers  and revenge and friendship and sex and  mortality and philosophy and all of  those things it's just the most heart  attack poetry around  you